we had a question come in from a viewer
Jacob he writes how do you share your
ideas without getting run over by other
writers or bullying them without getting
run over by them or bullying them how do
you share your ideas yeah I'm assuming
that it would mean you know like people
kind of poking holes in your idea and
and allowing them maybe to sway you from
your voice and I'm just assuming sorry
dude that's the tricky part yeah I mean
you can't avoid I mean pick who you
share it with wisely and pick the time
that you share it and the reason why
you're sharing it and what you're
looking for from sharing it and what you
tell them you're looking for when you
share it but even if you do all those
things other people are out of our
control and they might come back to you
with opinions and reactions that are
very you know unhelpful to you or
emotionally discouraging or devastating
to you and you may not be able to avoid
that I mean you can certainly work on
handling your own reactions but you
can't control what they're gonna say
much as you might try but if you're
conscious about all those things and
sort of being targeted and who you're
sharing and why and all those things and
also noticing that they may say things I
don't like and I don't have to let it
destroy my opinion about whatever I'm
writing however I am open I'm doing it
because I'm open to hearing other
opinions that I want to have a sense of
how others are reacting to it any one
person is not enough though it's
probably you need a consensus of people
and people who know something about what
you're trying to do people that
understand the craft are a more valuable
opinion than just kind of friends or
even other aspiring writers may not be
as valuable of an opinion to you so you
always have to take what others say with
somewhat of a grain of salt I think
while being open to if I get a lot of
the same opinion maybe there's something
worth looking at there I think it a lot
of it is you have to be like a detective
who's interested in knowing what are the
things that aren't working for people
and then I'll figure out why and I'll
figure out how to solve them if they say
you should do this other thing instead
don't listen to that don't try to do
their fixes but listen to what their
issues are which they may not even be
articulating because people try to be
helpful and tell you what if you did
this in
dad what you really want to know is why
do you not like what I did do and people
sometimes don't want to say it because
it's too hurtful like I was bored I
didn't care stuff like that or they may
not even know how to articulate they
just might know I didn't like it you
know is it helpful which is why we try
to codify some of these things of what
makes someone like or not like something
right so we can learn from that so I
think it's um you know trusting that
your own voice has value and that you
will find your way to address whatever
problems you decide you agree our
problems takes the power away from the
other random subjective people who are
gonna say whatever it is they're gonna
say I like that I like becoming a
detective and trying to solve it because
in that sense you're taking out some of
the personal feelings from it almost
you're almost you're acting as if you're
a third party and then it's less you're
you're less upset about it yeah that's
excellent so you're not something that
you're able to practice on a daily basis
I know you know 6 a.m. hits and it's
it's a new day for all of us in many
different things that we deal with but
is that something that you try to really
implement yeah I'm very careful and
selective about when I share stuff and
who I share it with because I know I'll
have a tendency to get very upset
depending on what people say and
sometimes it can threaten to derail me
from whatever it is I'm trying to do or
thinking there's any value in it so I've
really learned to be to really be
careful and to do it with the right
people at the right times for the right
reasons at the right times interesting
at the right times in the process cuz
sometimes you're ready it really helps
if you've moved on to another project
and you're not even thinking about this
one anymore to then show it to people
cuz then if they don't like it as much
you already have this other one that
you're now interested so I'm a big
believer in putting one down maybe not
even show it to anyone right away work
on something else come back to the first
one and you'll have new perspective and
you'll see things you want to change so
you make your own changes you never had
to show it to anyone at that point right
but eventually when you do show it maybe
have a couple other things that you're
working on so that that one script isn't
your whole world anymore right because
when you're in the middle of it it's
your baby and you better not have your
baby get abused by other people
so it helps to get that distance from it
and a lot of it is you get your own
distance from it you'll be able to give
yourself notes that you couldn't do when
you were in the middle of it
and you finished it to some extent
whether it's um it's the first draft
right where it where's your knot you
know I'm gonna throw this thing away
forget it
so-and-so said this because you've
you've actually gone through it so
that's that's interesting and it's
almost like a form of protection in a
way it is yeah it's another thing I got
from the war of already talked Steven
Pressfield somewhere I I noticed him
saying he would like finish a project
every six months I said to myself a
while back I'm gonna write two scripts a
year to the point where I feel they're
they're kind of finished they've gone
through multiple drafts of my own notes
maybe no one else's notes have yet come
into play but they've really been
rewritten significantly based on my own
notes and the way I get there is by
taking a pause moving away coming back a
couple months later to like finish one
but always have multiple scripts in the
hopper so some are done some are semi
done some you've just started and so it
becomes a little more of a factory as
opposed to I have this one project I've
been working on for three years and it's
all I ever think about every day if
someone doesn't like it I'm devastated
you know that is not the most helpful
way to go and I've done that
you